[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
traditionally it is a day of ceremony
hi barack hussein obama do solemnly
swear hi
dwight d eisenhower do solemnly swear
grandeur
[Music]
stretching back to america's founding
joe biden's is the 59th u.s presidential
inauguration
and across those more than 200 years of
history there have been some stand-ups
times when images have become iconic and
words have captured moments of
generational change
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
[Applause]
[Music]
moments of political transition
in this present crisis government
is not the solution to our problem
government
is the problem and sometimes moments
where americans were told what they most
wanted to hear
and maybe needed to believe about
themselves there is nothing wrong with
america that cannot be
cured by what is right with america
messages have been sent to both allies
and adversaries
we shall pay any price
bear any burden meet
any hardship support any friend
oppose any foe to assure the survival
and the success of liberty from this day
forward it's going to be only
america first
and a few inaugurations are remembered
only because something bizarre happened
like in 1841 when william henry harrison
wanted to prove he was tough
by speaking for two hours on a cold wet
day purposely without an overcoat
he died of pneumonia exactly a month
later
and 12 years earlier when andrew jackson
threw up in the white house to
anyone and everyone it got so out of
hand
he had to escape his own party by
climbing out a window
but the ones history most remembers are
the ones that captured a moment
and seemed to bend it to the new
president's will
in 1933 a nation teetering on the brink
of economic ruin heard these words
let me assert my firm belief
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself and by all accounts the
national mood began to change
perhaps appropriately the most famous
inaugural address was delivered by the
president often considered america's
greatest
in 1865 as the civil war drew to a close
abraham lincoln called for unity with
malice toward none he said with charity
for all
let us strive on to finish the work we
are in
to bind up the nation's wounds words
that
once again resonate in this deeply
divided america
of 2021 kamal santa maria al jazeera
washington